okay good morning everyone
and can i welcome everyone to this
meeting of development control committee
a at midsofa district council just need
to run through some of the domestic
arrangements before we get going can you
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking if you are attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you will be asked
to leave
can i also ask everyone to make sure
your mobile phones are on sign please or
switched off and could you also just
check the laptops that the volume is
right down
to avoid the pingings that come in when
emails come in
we will be using e-voting today
as we always do at mid suffolk planning
meetings
on the modern.gov.app
so please good members make sure they're
logged in and ready to use the app and i
see everyone has registered attendance
so thank you
if i can remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live on
the internet or be capable of repeated
viewings the whole of the meeting will
be recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you're
making a representation to the meeting
you'll be deemed by the council to have
consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded and
if we do hear the fire alarm today
please leave the building via the fire
exit make your way to the assembly point
at its richtown football club
if you can follow the signs directing
you to the fire exits at the end of each
room please do not enter the atrium the
ground floor area and walkways
if you are in the agent the time of the
alarm please follow the signs to the
nearest far exit signs
please use stairs and do not use the
lift and do not re-enter the building
towards safety just do so
right
so
just to run through well we haven't got
any members of the public here
but just for the benefit of anyone that
might be watching online we have on my
left
the members of the committee will be
making decisions with myself on the
applications before us today in
mid-suffolk district council the ward
member may speak but may not vote
then on the right hand side we have the
officers that will be presenting we have
gemma walker the area planning officer
jasmine wyatt the case officer ian de
prez the legal adviser
and claire and mandy on my right to left
who make sure everything ticks over
smoothly
and i think that's it so thanks everyone
we're now moving straight on to the
agenda
apologies for assets and substitutions
do we have any apologies please
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor barry humphries
thanks very much um do we need to
receive any declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
council mayor and councilman
yes um the agent mr rob bailey lives
within my ward and we are acquainted
thank you and councilman uh i'm the
event director for the park chrome which
uses the path uh within this site as
part of its route
anyone else no okay thank you for that
so it's supposed to say
no well we'll come on to any site visits
so um
okay uh
so that's just two non-pecuniary
interests really thank you
um decorations of lobbying any
declarations of lobbying none received
no thank you
decorations of personal site visits
councilmatterson i think you want to
come in on that yes i i've been there
many times thank you and councilman
uh i i'm usually um in that vicinity at
least twice a week not specifically look
at the planning application but on the
site okay thank you
okay so we'll move on now to the
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting that was held on the 6th of
september 22.
they run in our papers
from page 7
through to 18.
is everyone happy that i signed those as
a true record of the meeting is that oh
we have to sorry i always do this so we
have to go to the
app to vote on if we accept the minutes
can i have a proposal for the minutes
please council mayor and a seconder
councillor field thank you
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress in your app
thank you
thank you chair that's six votes four
and one abstention that's carried okay
thank you very much
you now need to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme any received
no received okay thank you okay so we
move on to the schedule of planning
applications we've got one application
before us today which is
dc2106052 northfield view
phase 2c land to the west of chilton
field
in stone market and now hand over to the
case officer jasmine wired to introduce
the application to committee
thank you chair and good morning members
i'm presenting a reserve matters
application for phase 2c of the
northfield view development today
this phase comprises of 234 dwellings
the reserve matters for consideration
are appearance landscaping layout and
scale
the principle of development was
established and the access and spine
road were approved under the outline and
associated infrastructure permissions
these dwellings notably do contribute to
the council's housing land supply
members are reminded that this
presentation should be viewed in
conjunction with the committee report
and it does not seek to replace any of
the content content within that
so here is the whole of the northfield
view development in context as you can
see chilton fields is located to the
west hand side and you've then got
agriculture land and the a14 to the
north one house is to the west and stone
markets to the east
northfield view is outlined in red
and as you can see some of the dwellings
have been delivered with a lot more
under construction in that northern area
of the site
the spine road has become being
constructed in full which of course
guides the overall layout of this phase
phase 2c falls south of the roundabout
roughly in the center of the screen
there
and in the center of the development
phase 2c is a central area outlined in
red all south of the central roundabout
as you can see again
phase 2b is the
area to the northern boundary of the
site which has been approved previously
phase 2d will then follow to the south
which is that area in blue
over the next three slides you'll see
the different areas of the northfield
view development
there are a scattering of listed
buildings shown in the orange
public rights way are shown dashed in
green
the built-up area boundary of stone
markets shown by the brown line and
green areas
will show protected trees
this slide shows the most northern half
of the development which has been
partially built out and shows part of
what will be phase 2b which was the one
previously approved
so this is the centre of the development
with the majority of land forming part
of phase 2c with the northern area of
the map then forming part of phase 2b
as you can see you've got some protected
trees and public rights away running
through this area
finally this is the southern uh area of
the development which again shows the
southern half of phase 2c and the land
that will be coming forward as part of
phase 2d
within that southern central gap outside
of the development area is corpus graves
as reflected in the tabled papers which
hopefully members will have had chance
to read there are some updates to be
made to the committee report
so highways landscaping and ecology
matters have all been resolved
there are likely to be some ecological
conditions which are likely to be
imposed as part of the recommendation um
however we've not been advised of the
specific recommended conditions as of
yet from place services but that is
that's pending
here is the site layout plan and it is a
higher density part of the site and its
layout and scale reflects this
as shown earlier the spine road is
already in place and the developable
parcels are heavily guided by that spine
road public open space is still proposed
totally 1.7 hectares
there are a range of housing sizes
scattered around the site with the
development proposing range of
two-bedroom to five-bedroom dwellings
the larger dwellings as you can see are
primarily located on the edge of the
development there but there are some
scattered within
a total of 47 affordable dwellings are
proposed all of which would be tenure
blind utilizing the same mix of
materials and architectural features as
all the other dwellings
the affordable dwellings would also be
cluttered and clustered and integrated
alongside the open market housing
they were comprised of a mixture of
affordable rent shared ownership and
discount market and would be delivered
in accordance with the section 106
agreement that was signed as part of the
outline permission
a total of 581 parking spaces are
proposed including 58 visitor spaces and
two unallocated spaces
there are seven instances of triple
parking where it is truly required as
per suffolk county council's parking
guidance
all of which are located down private
drives sort of to the outer edges and
near to the visitor parking
in terms of the story heights the
garages are single story dwellings are
two to two and a half stories and flats
are three stories
the site is highly permeable responding
to the existing public rights away
with a range of two meter wide footpaths
shown in the orange and the three metre
wide shed foot and cycleway shown in
yellow running in and around the site
the connections to the south show how
phase 2c will eventually feed into phase
2d
there are a range of boundary treatments
proposed around the site with brick
walls metal railings and low level post
and rail fencing in and around prominent
and visible locations and corners all
close builded fencing is concentrated
within the rear areas of the plots in
less visible locations
there are six character areas proposed
to help aid legibility around the site
with house types to reflect these
different areas
within the street scene there'll be a
variety of materials landscaping
architectural features and boundary
treatments offered by the combination of
house types and character areas which
again aids legibility and wayfinding
around the site
here we have a selection of the house
types and the two on the left show three
bedroom homes and the two on the right
show four um bedroom homes
uh here we have some further elevations
and floor plans and so the left image
shows a five bedroom house type and the
right shows block of the apartments all
of which would uh offer two bedrooms
the recommendation is therefore to
approve reserve matters thank you for
listening
thank you um questions i've i've got a
few but we'll go around the room first
we'll start at this end right around
counselor mayor first
thanks to just quickly um page 74
there's a statement that plot one two
one doesn't appear to have any private
outdoor immediate space was that a
mistake was that being resolved
uh is that in the highway section sorry
what which point is that
74
base services
oh yes that has been resolved as part of
the amended plan so the most up-to-date
um
consultation response we had through was
from place services landscaping as per
the table papers so they've reviewed
amended plans which that's all been
resolved it's just very difficult to
read numbers on things you can't expand
on
yes yeah no no that's something fine
thank you
we'll go around the room counselor even
um thank you very much
um
two clarifications please on page 24 at
the bottom it says um nhs england are
saying that they would use sill to fund
any future additional services but
obviously there's no
there's no sill from this side to
arenachus england aware that they
wouldn't get
sealed from the site if they need to
improve services folks uh yes they
should be i'm not sure if gemma because
you've dealt with some earlier phases um
yeah so although they wouldn't be so
specifically from this site because any
contributions would have been dealt with
under the outline we wouldn't be looking
at that reserve matters in any case but
if they still needed money through sale
obviously it comes in through a wider
funding pot in any case so there would
still flexibility through the sale
process
thanks and also on the um
housing um could you just clarify please
the issue about one bed properties um on
um from strategic housing it says that
they're across the whole of the
development or the a b c and d
there should be a certain percentage of
one-bed properties and it implies that
they'll have to then be a lot more
warm-bed properties in the following
phase
could you just clarify that because i'm
not clear that that would either happen
or that we should be asking for them
here or why they weren't here thank you
uh yes so in effect they there would be
a high proportion of one beds um in that
final phase that has been explained to
the the applicant and agent and that is
acknowledged um
obviously we are where we are but
the section 106 does require a certain
amount so they will be delivered and it
will have to be incorporated into that
final phase
thanks councilman
uh i too was going to ask about the um
the housing mix um
can you just explain what the amended
plan
um for this issue with the junction at
the parking places of plot 73 to 233 is
yes yeah so in effect um
i think there was a slight
miscommunication about what was actually
required from suffolk county council and
so there was a junction type access
which
would have given
motorists priority over pedestrians
which was originally proposed
following some further discussions an
amended plan has altered that junction
so it would serve it serves a parking
court
um but effectively what would what would
happen is there's a different junction
type now which is effectively a dropped
kerb
which enables pedestrians to have um
priority over over vehicles
cancer field
thank you
a couple of points one one it mentions
uh in in the report somewhere the uh
fabric first approach to
building to to the
performance of buildings i wonder which
version of building regulations will
apply is that the ones when the outline
was
agreed is it the one that means it's
today or the one that will exist in
whenever it is june or july or whatever
um
so effectively building regulations will
apply at the point that they come to
build um obviously building regulations
are not planning matters so we we can't
really go into you know further detail
on that but in terms of the building
regs and it will be whatever
has come into play when they're building
it at the point they're actually
laying bricks or digging foundations
okay
uh second point really
just the um i looked for the 106. i
couldn't find it online anywhere i don't
know whether it is uh i was concerned
about the uh
sort of requirements on the
establishment and maintenance of the
open space which is
quite appreciative
uh i believe it would have been within
the section 106. um
i'm not entirely sure where it would be
available online but it certainly is
within the public domain and i believe i
don't know if gem is aware i'm
sure that there would have been
something in there
that related to the open space
management
i thought there was taylor and who might
be able to answer quicker than we can so
perhaps we'll come back that i will just
have a check and make sure and we'll
double check it goes on the system if
it's not there
and and check for that answer as well if
that's okay
thank you yes
okay that's right
thank you yes um
yes
slide eight um
i think really
in terms of if that's showing the the
the constraints
um
i think it should also be showing the
visually important open space of
porpoise graves which is although it's
not a butting two b c what we're on now
c
um it does actually
you know it is on the edge of phase two
d
um so i think we should be recognizing
that it's it's there on that if you've
got that
slide handy eight
would wish
you know members to be clear
of its existence and importance
difficult
um
thank you yeah can i give prior notice
the next questions on on slide 15 but on
this one
it's the
it's it's the
it's that rectangle yep that's
broadly that is it that is the pulpes
graves um
v ios which is um is very
heavily wooded and indeed um owned and
maintained by the oneness parish council
um
thanks for that one so on on slide 15
what i wanted to just um
winkle out and be clear about was on the
connections um
wait for it
yeah right yes so um
yeah it was a bit of a quick visit to
this this i think the the key
point that i wanted to understand
and see on there is is this bus gate
which is in the extreme
bottom left-hand corner
uh i think south west in infravisera
um
yeah so that that is
a road going to there capable of taking
buses is that right
uh yes that's that's correct and a bus
gate has been quite extensively
discussed with um suffolk county council
when the the agent and applicant during
the process of this application just to
make sure that
everything is in place if that um
bus service is eventually delivered
which i think is part of the
outline there is there's a condition or
something in the section 106 which
relates to it um but all of the roads
within within the site as in the spine
road um
would be
well they're six meters wide so they're
able to accommodate buses
right yeah and on also on that um that
the the threshold of 300
for providing that
or making it open
is that
we i was i mean because that that bus
gate goes right back to the outline of
the allocation of the whole site and
everything um
which 300 houses is that dependent upon
trigger triggering
because i mean the smaller 300 up there
already overall
yes um
i think i would defer that to the
applicant um who may be slightly more
aware of the the specific trigger point
but notably there is an element further
along from the site which didn't relate
to the overall outline it was previous
to that so there's you've only got phase
2a that has basically been built out and
then phase 2b is the one that's been
approved
um
so once whatever the trigger point is
that's at the point that it will be
delivered but there probably are
300 houses overall but not within as
part of this outline
i think i don't think that makes it
remotely clear which 300 what it is
the allocation
750 originally so this part of uh
children needs this for 600 was what the
outline was for so i think jasmine's
saying out of the original allocation
you've got to take off a certain number
that we've dealt with previously and
then the bus gate would be based on this
600 so about halfway through
the totality of this site but again
taylor if we may well have a well i was
hoping
i'm hoping with that the council rather
than the the
because it's in control of the situation
please yes but in terms of their
build-out planning so they will
obviously have a plan for the numbers of
build out and the time over which that
will take so they would know when it is
going to be
hitting that target
but we can come back to that i'd like to
be independently able to monitor when it
is would it be useful if i just go um
back a second to i've got a slide which
kind of shows what has been built out
that might be useful
so as you can see here there's a range
of houses kind of along this bit here
which is outside of that north field
view as in what relates to this um
reserve matters and the outline so this
is the whole outline area
as you can see you've got phase 2a that
is
obviously there is some some level of
build out here you've then got phase 2b
which hasn't yet uh been i mean they may
well have started construction but it
certainly hasn't been built out and then
obviously phase 2c
is this bit here so at the point that
they hit 300 within this red line
that will be if that is the trigger
point that will be the point that
the bus will have to be provided
so it's within the whole of phase
two is what you're saying
yes yeah i spoke yeah because obviously
not outside that red line we've got
phase one yes yep
right okay three hundred within five
like that's john you want to come up on
that point i'm just gonna make the point
shouldn't this be in the 106 agreement
which is one of the reasons i did
question before that it wasn't available
no i think
i think i have found this online if it's
this is the one relating to the outline
permission for application o seven one
six would tell you that you've got it if
you've got it as well jasmine
have we both got it
uh yeah i think you've you'll probably
yeah i've i've got to hear it's complete
between the council and taylor
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the one
with between the council and taylor
wimpy dated 5th of july 2018
i've just it's quite obviously as you'd
expect it's quite long and complex so
um i'm sorry councillor phil
gemma has it as well so
have a quick look for the bus gate yeah
one where i'd come up with just the nhs
query so we had an nhs capital
contribution through the 106. so i found
that so we've that will have been done
per dwelling and then the public open
space has got a management maintenance
requirement through the 106 as well so
hopefully that's some of the previous
points but we'll have a look we'll come
back to bus
we'll look that up okay count surpass
more over to you
um thanks matthew um just a couple of
points um i just wanted to check
um
i think was the parish council at one
house asked for some page 24
early planting um on the west now that's
fine but clearly we need to use common
sense so you wouldn't want to start
doing it in the middle of july you want
to do it in the autumn i don't know when
they're going to start the uh the
building work but it does need to be
done also want to be absolutely sure
that um if it's in the 106 agreement
that looking after the landscaping
scheme until it is
well established sustainable native
species and so on i'm just
imagining that's all in there and the
other comments i'd just like to
issue to raise
and i'd often raise this in a larger
state like this can we make sure that
there is much permeability in the
driveways and so on as possible
can i say we're going to have to we'll
come back to that point well i'm just
asking is that what is in there really
is is that they just wanted to be
clarified that
and um can i also ask when it comes to
the um ecological report and so on is
there a provision for things like um
swift boxes and
house marking cups etc
that's it
thank you
thank you so in terms of your first
point in relation to the landscaping um
there is a condition proposed as part of
this reserve matters which will
basically um
require the landscaping to be
implemented as approved at kind of the
earliest point that it can be
um obviously within the relevant
planting seasons
um then in terms of the permeable
surfaces
um obviously suffolk county council have
reviewed all of the the surfaces and the
specific materials and they're happy
that there isn't any sort of issue in
terms of the permeability of them
what i'm trying to get at we live in one
of the driest parts of the country and i
bring this up at
other meetings what we don't want well i
don't want personally personal view is
that we have a lot of hard impermeable
surfaces on the driveway so that the
water percolates through as far as
possible not being draconian about it
into the aquifer that's all i'm asking
there are all sorts of ways you can do
that yeah and that might be i mean the
specific technical details it might be
worth um asking that of the applicant an
agent
thank you
um and
the ecological bits yes
um i believe that we have a lot of those
bits and pieces
i don't think it was specifically
mentioned as part of the application but
it's certainly something that we can
include as part of the sustainability
measures and
i'm assuming but place services normally
require um biodiversity enhancement
measures um so again that will kind of
be
i suppose covered by that
thank you
can i ask several questions so electric
uh car charging points is there one at
every property
uh there isn't one at every property and
part of the reason for that will be
because there are uh parking courts so
it does make it quite difficult to have
the ev charging points for each property
and there is an ev charging condition as
recommended by suffolk county council
highways
so notwithstanding the submitted plans
they will have to submit further
specific details and obviously we can
try and maximize the amount that that
they've kind of provided so what
percentage of what house i mean how
what properties how many don't have it i
mean is it 50
70 so there's there's 98 of the 234 that
do
have ev charging so i'm not sure what
that is expressed as a percentage but
so
yeah i mean
obviously it's something that we can
review as part of as part of the
proposed condition anyway
um
it might be that you want to ask further
i can ask the applicant yeah thanks and
can i ask how the properties are heated
yes
they are heated by gas boilers so gas
runs out in 2030 what happens after that
point
uh
this is something you know we can't
assess things on the basis of something
happening in the future we have to
assess them at the present time
and at the present time gas is not
prohibited so
they it's effectively
building rigs yeah i mean we get this on
every application um
solar panels i couldn't see one on any
of the drawings are there any on any of
the properties uh there aren't any on
any of the properties as proposed within
these submitted plans um however
we have discussed it with the applicant
and they are willing to they've kind of
identified that they're willing to
include some pv um
panels so again the specific amount you
know we can discuss as part of a
condition um that might be something we
need to add into the recommendation is a
proposed condition some is very could be
two or is it 234. i would uh i don't
think it will be 234 but it's something
that again i would ask the applicant
triple parking how many properties have
triple parking
uh so there's seven triple parking
spaces that are required
yeah of course um
right so most of the well all of the
triple parking that is proposed that is
a requirement as per suffolk county
council is along these sort of areas so
you can see there's two and then a
garage space
and these are all the private driveways
can you see
my mouse i don't know if it's that clear
but
well thank you
all right there we go
um so yeah you can see there's a couple
here uh there's some further ones down
here i think they're along this side as
well so they are the kind of outer edge
ones serving the slightly large
properties and obviously you can then
see that there are the orange visitor
spaces as well uh quite in close
proximity to where you've got this kind
of triple parking
there are some other instances where it
is um happening so you can kind of see
along some areas here
um this is actually surplus to the
requirement so they only
in in accordance with suffolk county
house's parking guidance
these plots would only actually need two
parking spaces which they have provided
and then the garage is is surplus to
that requirement
um yeah if i can come back with with
another question now that we're talking
about parking um
is the can you tell us what the housing
density of this particular phase 2c is
in comparison
with the site as a whole
and of 2a and 2b
because looking at the plan there do
seem to be an awful lot of parking
courts
and i'm just wondering whether they've
crammed a lot of houses in because um we
know what how people behave with parking
courts and they'll all park right
outside their front door on the road so
i'm a bit worried about the
amount of housing we've actually crammed
into this particular phase thank you
yes thank you um so as part of the
overall scheme this was always kind of
envisaged to be the area that had the
higher density
and i believe 2b i'm not sure on 2a i
would have to
probably go and find that and come back
to you on that but 2b
uh i believe i had just found it
sorry bear with me just a second
uh so in in phase 2b which was for a
hundred dwellings it was 24.2 dwellings
per hectare i believe this one is now at
um 33 dwellings per hectare
what was the what is the
you know on the on the outline when they
came for the whatever it was um gemma
said 700 and 600 and something houses on
the whole of whole of
phase two what is the average density
would that give um that wouldn't have
been set as part of the outline and i'm
not sure if there was any indication
there was a number of houses divided by
the area will give us the dwellings per
hectare
yes i'm not entirely sure off the top of
my head i probably would have to go away
and work that out and but i can try and
do that
okay do we have the bus
gate answer i'm still looking i don't
know if ian found anything on the bus
thank you yeah the the um yes the uh the
other thing i just wanted to to clarify
and reassure
um page 35
um
there's there's a couple of references
to the sub-market area action and
s-a-a-p
at 6.8 8.2 it this various policies um
with which this application um accords
um i just thought i'd better ask are
there any policies in the saap that this
does not accord with
uh i don't believe so because a lot of
it related to the original outline
because obviously it was part of an
allocation
um so a lot of those guided the overall
i suppose guiding principles of of the
um development and again a lot of them
were dealt with as part of the outline
and so yeah i don't believe that there
are any
that it doesn't accord with any
conflicts
okay any other questions before we move
on we will come back to the points
raised as soon as we get the answers and
we can the applicant may be able to
answer some of those so we'll move on so
um
[Music]
sorry john you want a quick question
yeah just a quick one returning to the
bus gate for an instance um
i know these can be quite difficult to
get yet right and councillor pasmore has
one in his area that um
he's notorious for allowing cars and
vans and god knows what through as well
some assurance that this one has
itself county council has improved the
design so this will
achieve its function which is to let
buses through but not everybody else who
fancies using that
uh yes thank you so i believe well we
did have quite a few discussions about
this specific point um both the
applicant agent and suffolk county
council highways and there were there
was kind of a tune throwing just to get
this this specific point right and i
believe as a result of that some of the
the visitor parking was moved as well to
kind of discourage cars being
in that specific location
um but yeah that that has been a kind of
central consideration of it
okay thank you
yes may i be reminded of councillor
phil's precise question on
the woods
a
maintenance sorry i was talking about
the maintenance of the
uh open spaces and the construction and
whether that was included in 106
and whether there were
sums of money assigned for that or
whether basically they're concerned
about the maintenance and the
probability that that could eventually
fall upon the residents in the area in
an unfair way well i've just i've got i
have got it in front of me the um the
list of planning obligations relevant to
the
district council as opposed to the
county
as you'd expect a long list so owner's
obligation to the district council
affordable housing which we haven't been
talking about this morning in detail
and then
moving down the list
nhs capital contribution
public open space
that as you as is usual and standard
there's a requirement for a scheme which
i'm sure has been in
and
play areas
adoption provisions for adoption of the
land by an appropriate person
transfer of it for a nominal
consideration all the usual sort of
thing you would expect
i can't immediately see i mean i think i
suppose it depends on what the scheme is
in these matters that there's a standard
requirement where you have an outline
permission to have an open space scheme
which would be
come with reserve matters but again i
think we may have to speak to the
applicant about that then there's a
reference to sports pavilion land if
that's
of any interest
yeah i'll just say i'm more than happy
i'm sure the applicant can help us out
but i would just say that we are looking
at the reserve matters which doesn't
include the access we are looking at the
appearance landscaping allowance scale
on this case
okay thank you
okay well thank you for that so we'll
now move on um we don't have uh the the
town council or par obviously parish
council um we don't have an objector we
don't have a supporter
uh but we do have the agent uh and the
applicant so we have andrew wright the
applicant and james bailey the agent
so um over to you you have three minutes
whenever you're ready and we do ask you
to keep the three minutes and we have
the timer here thank you
good morning chair members my name is
james bailey and i'm the planning
consultant that has been working
alongside telu-me on their northfield
view site for a number of years now
i'm joined this morning by andrew wright
who is the senior technical manager for
design and planning at taylor wimpy's
east anglia region and between us we
should be able to answer any of the
questions that you may have this morning
we're here to discuss a further
connecting phase of the northfield view
development at stone market which
continues to be a highly successful and
popular site for taylor wimpey in the
region
the existing road and infrastructure
already in place on site continues to
guide how these phases are being brought
forward
this is a reserved matters application
referred to as phase 2c which will link
between the housing in phase 2b to the
north and with the future phase 2d to
the south
consent is being sought for 234 new
dwellings which would include 20
affordable housing units as required as
part of the section 106 agreement
the houses to be constructed are similar
to those on the previous phases of
development as are the materials to be
used with the aim of being of achieving
a consistent approach across the whole
development
the master plan for northfield view has
been commended for its connections and
permeability with a strong network of
footpaths bridal ways and cycle
connections being implemented across the
whole development
this phase continues to create legible
frameworks of new landscaping open
spaces and green corridors which
provides an attractive setting for the
new homes as well as providing new areas
of habitat for wildlife
the submission of this application
follows extensive pre-app discussions
with officers to agree the details of
the scheme
as with the previous phases taylor wimpy
have continued to carry out a
comprehensive public engagement exercise
prior to submitting this application and
have discussed this phase with stone
market town council as well as the
parishes of onehouse and hawley no
objections have been raised by any of
the stakeholders
this application has been carefully made
in accordance with the stone market area
action plan the adopted development
brief for chilton lease emerging policy
documents on all of the previous
planning consents
the principle of development
is now well established some years ago
and the northfield view site features
heavily within the council's strong
housing land supply position
approval of this application today will
enable taylor wimpy to continue to
deliver houses on this popular and
strategically important site and i would
therefore respectfully request that
members endorse their office's
recommendation and approve this
application this morning
thank you very much for your time and we
are here to answer any questions you may
have
thank you very much okay i'm sure we
have got questions so accounts we'll
start off at the same go around as we
did before council mayor first
thank you
98 charging points
do you have any idea what are the
criteria for whether a house has a
charging point is it all with four and
five bedroom houses or is it all the
one-bedroom houses
uh morning german morning members um i
think the decisions we've made regarding
the ev charging at the moment is based
on what we can do in terms of the
building regulatory requirements so
there's no existing policy for ev but as
a developer we're looking at
ways of assuming what our customers will
want in the future so at the moment the
ev provision shown before you today is
based on us pushing the envelope as far
as we can
the the biggest restriction that we've
got in place is the the rear carport at
the car court sorry
where they then become remote and
actually having cable runs across
third-party land becomes a big
constraint upon us
so to answer your question it's based on
wherever you've got on-plot parking
it's not specific to a larger property
for example it's wherever we had the
opportunity we'd look to do so
thank you now just follow up that point
so why can't you just bury the cable and
have a pop up at each parking court
like others do
it is possible to do that um it does
just create a lot of issues with the
crossing third party land
so if you look at the forthcoming
building regulations coming into play in
2023
they actually steer people away from
that due to those complexities and it's
really
a case of if there is an issue with your
ev charging at home and you need to rip
up that cable at some point it may will
be crossing an adoptable highway uh some
form of public open space etc it creates
additional problems
and it becomes sort of there's
integrated legal matters with that so
we're encouraged by building regulations
to steer away from that
however the flip side of that is to
maximise where you can you've got the
opportunity to do so
go around the top
um thank you thank you chair um i've got
two questions if i may firstly um
pv on roofs um just
can you
advise why you're not doing this
as a developer kind of about oh 200
meters away
um on other sites putting pv on all the
roofs on one of their developments so
i'd just like to know why you're not i'm
using a similar approach for your
site and my second question is with
regards to
the
nationally described space standard
51
of the affordable housing does not meet
the nationally described space stand on
on this site and i just want to know why
that is thank you
on this development with uh i've
answered your second part first of all
mate so regarding the ndss
it's fair to say that not all of our
homes on this development we are
compliant with those larger increased
space standards um for us at the time
when this application was considered
under the outline um those standards
were not part of that consideration
so in terms of the unit numbers and
housing delivery everything was based
upon what you've got before you today um
things have moved forward and ndss has
become more and more relevant so where
we've been able to do so we've tried to
maximize the percentage of those homes
that can and as i believe you suggested
in excess of 50 of the homes do comply
with that um regarding the provision of
pv
um that really is a very open question
uh very reasonable to ask um as part of
our sap assessment so the standard
assessment procedure when we look at our
homes in terms of the fabric performance
of those
we do consider a number of technologies
including the renewables such as
photovoltaics
to date historically we've not gone down
the route of adding pv
instead we've gone for a fabric first
approach and whereby we've we've
insulated the homes better um which
means you don't require those
technologies to get through the sap
calculation um however what i would say
building rigs is moving on and by the
time we actually build out this phase we
may well be subject to
new building regulations and it may will
be a consideration at that point
as i say at the moment we don't need to
do it for the sat calculations but we do
offer it as an option for our customers
on this development
so it's there if people wish to take it
up
thank you thank you very much for that
much appreciated could i just come back
on the um space standards because um it
is over 50 don't
meet it and i just thought in in the
time that's happened since the um
previous developments to aim to be
surely you could have got a better
um
you know percentage if not all fine but
is there any chance that you can
actually improve on that before
we get to develop you know the stage i
mean it's i just don't think it's
acceptable otherwise thank you
yeah i think it's fair to say that um
these smaller homes are probably the
ones subject to not being ndss compliant
in comparison to the larger homes
as i believe the officer's presentation
explained this is tending to be a higher
density character area so phase two c
and which we've got before you today
probably has a lower ndss compliant
ratio on that basis when we look to
build that phase 2d that will the layout
become more looser and some larger units
will come into force um equally i would
say taylor wimpy's looking at
new housetop range as we speak
and we're trying to introduce those onto
this development so for those of you who
have been partied to visiting site in
recent weeks you may will see a bit of a
reshuffle in terms of our show area for
example
where we're looking to utilize newer
house types and moving forward new house
types which then will bring into ndss
compliance in and increase that
percentage
uh thank you um i've got a few points
that i'm trying to form into questions
um given that this is the one of the
higher density parts of the development
can you explain why there are still
few one and two bedroom properties and
yet you've just said
phase 2d is going to be less dense and
therefore have some larger units and
we've heard from the officer that phase
2d needs to have more of the
one-bedroomed properties in it
this is my first point
if that makes sense
yes it's quite correct as the officer's
presentation explained there will be
additional one beds in the subsequent
phase um it really is just down to when
we've looked at this development rather
than draw it in isolation and we've
actually tried to draw all of the 600
homes as one
one large proving layout and the reason
we brought before you this application
in a smaller piece i think it allows
easier consideration for members um but
those one beds are coming at a later
date it's more cumulative why that why
that coverage will drop off a little bit
um because we've got more um external
spaces fronting into open space and i
believe uh one of the members made
reference to the likes of the
publisher's graves it's poss areas to
the south so invariably we would look to
loosen the layout in those scenarios but
yes you the one beds will come forward
if i can just add to that as well i
think people have mentioned uh various
things uh earlier in the discussion uh
they mentioned the the area action plan
uh the policies that are sort of guiding
this development and we must remember
that when we were doing that area action
plan back in 2008 2009 times
on there there was also a development
brief
that a lot of people were involved in
obviously that set out how the whole uh
of chilton leaves was going to come
forward including including the original
phase which we often tend to forget the
first 215 houses and and the primary
school from there but what we've now got
is the sort of the middle phase which
was always intended to be the high
density area on there
what we've then got and this is not in
front of us today so it's a bit
difficult to sort of have a discussion
about uh phase two c uh and obviously
without talking about phase 2d even
though that is not an application in
front of us we need to be mindful that
whatever is determined here today is
going to have an influence on how 2d and
particularly the purpose graves is going
to look we're probably all aware that
there may be other requirements of that
particular phase
later on down the line in terms of
sports provision and how that's going to
look
but in terms of what we've got in front
of us today
there is the 234 houses it was always
intended to be a higher density
obviously not towards the east and
towards the west which is
defined by its sort of rural edge
character to the west and
butting on to to children fields the
playing fields on there but it's already
been contained by the the existing road
network now what we've got uh is uh is a
series of different types of properties
around the open spaces that have been
an important part of the uh of the
development brief because it's important
to remember that there were specific
views uh that were identified all those
years ago particularly to uh to various
churches uh and to various access points
so that people would be able to see uh
from where we are on the top of
of northfield view looking down towards
various areas and that has dictated
the sort of density and where we can
actually fit some of these these
particular types of houses and numbers
in what it does mean is there is going
to be a a requirement that is going to
be placed on this final phase later on
down the line that we will have to
address
and the points that i think people have
raised in terms of different types of
housing mix
that the the officers from the the
authority have identified is something
that we
as a developer are very aware of i think
again in terms of consultation that will
be a very interesting element we know
that uh the people from from one house
have been very keen of how it's going to
deal with the pauper's graves but if i
refer it back what we've got in front of
us
this morning to determine is the 234
houses and how that that started to look
so hopefully that gives people a little
bit of context of still things to be
determined later okay yes you want to
come back back with my my other query uh
relating to the rear parking courts and
the ev provision
given that we've been told that magic
number 98 houses are going to have is
that right 98 houses are going to have
an ev charging point
do i take it that the remaining 136
dwellings
all have parking in rear parking courts
and um i presume that this is something
that taylor wimpy
um i'll have on other
developments um and
what is your experience of people using
rear parking course or do they all park
across the lovely nice wide bike path
and block it or are they parking on the
road thank you
we have across our developments we have
strong usage of our rear parking courts
they're not desirable i think it's a
fair comment um it's sometimes a
constraint applied by the character area
of the development and the requirements
of the higher density
um to answer your questions specific to
the provision of the ev
what we've put before you today is as
i suggested based upon if you've got
on-plot parking
it's not a case of every other parking
space as a rear car court it's where
you've got segregation between your
parking provision and the may will be
adoptable road or an adoptable footpath
as the incidents may will be
as i explained there's elements which
can be overcome and as i believe as the
officer's presentation suggested at the
start um it may well be that we can take
that away and look to to improve the
quantum of pv i'm sorry ev charging
on this development by seeing where we
can cross localized areas such as public
footpaths for example um sorry not a
public footpath in the sense of a public
right-of-way but as in a footpath
creation i think it becomes very
difficult when you've got a completely
remote rear car court um but there's
opportunities for us to explore some of
this and ken can you answer my my query
about um i mean particularly if you've
got any rear parking course in phase one
which is now
pretty much occupied
what what would you feel is the use the
resident use of a rear parking court in
your developments
regardless of whether they've got ev
points on just do people actually park
in them
uh yes i think it's the short answer um
yeah we get
we've not had in terms of our customer
services department um believe me the
two biggest issues we have are parking
and bins um on northfield view i'm
pleased to say uh we have very little
kickback in that regard um people do use
the rear car cords it seems to work well
um they are allocated parking space
we do have a quantum of visitors parking
then within them as well because
everybody have people visiting their
homes but yeah excellent usage to be
honest um and they're relatively well
landscaped as well so they are a
pleasant environment to park and be in
as part of your extended home
and what is the sort of natural
surveillance of the rear parking courts
um
do the you know do the houses
you know
can people view them or do people feel
that they're a you know a dodgy area
because they're around the back
um they tend to be well lit um one of
the things we do make sure is we we
always consult with the secure by design
officer and get their feedback
invariably they look for an element of
observation that can be undertaken so
typically you'll see a 1.8 meter closed
board defense reduced to 1.5 with
trellis on the top that allows an
element of observation in those areas um
they're not dark dingy spaces and those
days have gone thankfully for us all
they are as i say a pleasant environment
to park your vehicle and a safe
environment to do so
thank you councillor field do you have
any questions
i think so
just surprised your recent comments
you're telling us that ev
charging is extremely difficult because
one has to install cables across
third-party land
you also just told us the rear parking
courts are well lit
uh lighting usually to me involves
electricity and leds or something like
that so presumably you can resolve the
problem when you're putting lights in
but can't resolve it when you're trying
to charge a car
it seems slightly
strange so i'll leave that to you
um
the point i was making really is about
the building legs you're talking about
fabric first
i've now have the officers reassurance
but i just want to be sure which version
what we're doing in this development
because as i understand it we're
supposed to be
agreeing what will be done
not agreeing a framework in which you
and the officers can
develop a plan um
so
just to go to building rigs the new
version which is coming out in june
uplifts insulation by 30 percent i think
perhaps
as equally as important
ensures that the heating system the
radiators basically are designed for
a
i think a 55 degree c
flow temperature which allows you to
subsequently retrofit the boilers
with
heat pumps because heat pumps can't
achieve 70 degree flow temperatures
and that is critical to future residents
because there is a
cost associated which i'm sure
yourselves literally
point out
but there you go
so i'm trying to be certain about which
version of the building rigs you'll be
building to that when you talk about
fabric first
it will be to the new ohio standard
and
i think that
higher standard also brings sap
calculations which insist on a certain
amount of redundable energy generated at
the property
which is an obvious feeder for
the solar panels which you seem
reluctant to install
i do realize they're sort of 100 quid
each nowadays so it's not trivial to put
eight of them on the roof but there you
go
so if you could answer those
questions the ones that really were
questions i'd be grateful thank you
i think i'll be able to answer those and
so i suppose
that the main crux of your questions
relating around the fabric approach and
the building regulatory changes so we
are in a transitional period with the
building regulations uh you're quite
right to to highlight that and what's
very difficult for us
as a developer as to support this
application is that unfortunately the
sap software for the emerging builder
building regulations to come into play
as of june of next year as you um
articulated um isn't available yet
so unfortunately the government's on a
little bit of a go slow um that's been
promised to us since probably september
of last year still unavailable
and it's why we can't uh agree with
absolute certainty on what we will be
doing on future phases um but what we do
know is that
we do have gas on this development and
we will be looking to install gas
boilers as of today that's what our
energy statement uh support this
application makes reference to we also
know what building rigs we're building
to now i with the current sap software
and what we can make reference to
june 2023
build regulations changes there's a
shift as you uh it just explained part l
and the f is changing it will be looking
for an increased
u-value performance so the external
walls the floors the loft insulation
etcetera doors fenestration everything
will need to improve um that should
lower heating bills for for our
customers
it ensures a
better building envelope
but to accompany that you're quite
correct that there's a regulatory shift
towards encouraging people to install
the likes of air source heat pumps or
get away from gas boilers that's
something that tailor when people will
be looking to do
also adaptability in our homes so when
those customers if they do have gas
boilers on our current phases or future
phases those houses can be converted to
the likes of air source heat pumps
you can change to oversized radiators
elements such as that um
i'm hoping i've covered the your answer
can i just follow up on that particular
point then just
john do you mind if i just follow up on
that point so i mean we get many build
many house builders that come here and
we get some that come in and say the
building rates are changing in 2023
we're already delivering what we expect
to be in the 2023 we're building today
to 2023 standards and we're putting in
air source heat pumps because that's the
future and in fact we're way ahead of
the 2023 but what you keep saying is
well it's changing and we'll catch up in
2023 will you talked about in 2023 uh
will when the new regs come in that's
when we'll make the changes to pv panels
in 2023 that's when we're going to
change to
air source heat pumps so is the policy
not to be
looking ahead but just to change as the
building regs change because we get very
different story from other builders that
come before this committee who are
making all those changes now and have
come in here and said they've scrapped
gas and they're doing air sore easements
not all of them i might add but some
understood and if this was a if this was
a new development a complete standalone
one i probably would be coming and
talking to you about us doing exactly
that because this is a continuation
phase for us there's a lot of continuity
in what we're doing on that development
however um i don't wish to mislead
anybody i'm not saying that it will be
june 2023 that we'll make the step
change because we're forced to do it i'd
actually quite like to be doing it in
advance of that the issue we have we
don't have the sap software to back up
what that is so if other
yep
yeah and you can do that you can make
you can make the step change now um i
don't know um i can't speak on behalf of
other developers and what's been put
forward before members um but there are
a few issues in the current markets that
we're all aware of there's an energy
crisis for example um electric heating
costs around four times as much as gas
as of today
as a responsible builder we're looking
at that because actually it makes more
economical sense to run off gas at the
moment
that's not future-proofed and we fully
understand that air source heat pumps or
other alternatives are going to be the
way forward
so that is a consideration for us
equally at the moment if you do provide
air source heat pumps under the current
building regulations um part of the sap
software so the standard assessment
procedure it generates a pea which is a
predicted energy assessment um under a
gas boiler that gives you an a rating
which obviously from a sales and
marketing perspective is exactly what
our customers would be looking for if we
changed over an source heat pump just a
straight swap it drops you down to
around a c rating at the moment so
suddenly you're trying to market
something
um which is down to a c and customers
are like oh what does that mean in
conjunction with rising energy costs at
the moment as a developer we're a little
bit uncomfortable with making that step
change we're going to have to do it we
will do it but we want to do it in a
managed format so taylor wimpy as a
group is trying to understand with the
evolution of the building regulations
what we would do to complement air
source heat pumps and there's been
several comments raised today regarding
photovoltaics for an example and pv
where we've
today chosen to focus more on a fabric
first approach rather than add a
technology so we're trying to make the
homes cheaper to run before you then put
something on top when the real building
regulations
change all the software comes forward
and we can actually say with
absolutely you know definite the
definition as it were we're likely to
bring in pv as a standard approach and i
would have loved to sat here before
members today and spoken about
introducing air source heat pumps and
photovoltaics and in all honesty that is
what we are very very likely to do on
these homes but i don't want to deceive
any members today and say that's what
we're going to do because we just don't
have the sap software available to us at
the moment to confirm that approach
um i think that was very useful
explanation so thank you for that uh
cancer field back to you did i return
yeah i could point out it sounds like
you're using the 2013 tap software which
i
is only a spreadsheet which i certainly
are using there are commercial packages
available that are much better than that
um but this is not a debate this is
questions so the next question i really
had was well this one about
open space the provision of it
um
just to be certain that that
you're providing presumably at
considerable cost what about the
maintenance of open space and indeed the
maintenance of
uh the various private drives we talk
about which seems to be roads that serve
several houses
conventionally that's put upon some form
of management company which can be
local resident driven can be developer
driven can be some in independent group
i wondered what taylor wimpy's policy is
obviously my concerns were around
the reasonableness of the cost for an
amount of maintenance that has to be
done
we all understand maintenance costs
money but you know it can be a
world of difference between a
resident-run company
and
some organisation which is um
in it for the profit here
so i wonder if you could just make it
clear to me what you're doing thank you
so so this development um or this phase
of the development i should say would
follow uh what we've done previously um
which is where we'd have a management
company uh taking uh care of all of our
open space provision um as you've
alluded to that that's there's
invariably a monthly charge on our
customers for that um that's something
that we've been able to look at
previously and we'll look to do on this
on this scheme um that monthly chart
from our perspective needs to be at a
reasonable rate so customers can afford
to do it and i'm pleased to say that
that's an acceptable level on the
historical um phases and we'll continue
to be on this one so all of the open
space will be uh covered by that
management management company
just return i mean i i'm aware of
locations of large developments where
the management challenges have
quadrupled
from what's reasonable to four times
what's reasonable i'll just make sure
that you can assure us that does not
happen in your operations
yeah um so there's some longevity um in
that question uh from our perspective
it's always a little bit subjective what
is an acceptable amount to pay on a
management company charge um i don't
have to hand the figure in front of me
today what we've got on the previous
phase but i know as a business we deemed
that to be acceptable for customers and
i i know again we spoke about customer
service a moment ago we don't have
any issues with what's being offered
it's it's part of the point of sale
customers are fully aware that it's a
consideration for their affordability
when they buy that development um i know
it's explained to them exactly what that
money goes towards and how it's looked
after
so madison
thank you well yeah it's a little bit
unfair being the last person each time
most of my questions have been asked but
good i haven't
i haven't liked any of the answers that
i've heard so far
so i'm gonna pick up some of them a
little bit further right let's take the
the electric vehicle charging parking
course first now
this committee and indeed the other
committee because i'm there sometimes um
you know have heard and gradually worked
to
a kind of acceptable
point where trunking is provided
to the parking courts
to enable in the future
the electricity be taken there mr
council fields made a very good point
that the the lighting will have got the
electric there already anyway
so
that you know can you not at least do
what the other
developers are doing of providing the
trunking that's the first question
um
[Music]
so the second question
revisits the question of the building
regulations 2023 so
what we're looking at is 234
dwellings
and
you will need to
start
applying new regulations to to vote that
the houses and then flats that you
haven't commenced
by 12 months time
and knowing the speed at which things
move
i think that's quite a high
challenge so you know i think you really
need to be further ahead as the chairs
also
said on that um you know can you really
commence them all before next june i
don't think so really
so that's that's the second problem that
i have to answer those two questions
yeah yeah fine yeah go for it
yeah just to respond to that to that
second point we we won't have commenced
them before the trigger point of june
2023 and i apologize if i didn't
articulate that correctly in my response
earlier
my what we will be building those to the
june 2023 standards in all likelihood
the reason we can't sit before you today
and confirm that is because of this
purely because of the sap software not
being available to be able to confirm
what that will be but we will be
building as you've correctly explained
to the revised standards which is why
we've spoken about the lack of pv on
this development um as a standard
approach on the previous phases um i'm
quite happy to sit here today and and
talk about there will be pv on this
phase um but we've not put it before
members because i don't wish to to
deceive or anybody because we just don't
because the energy statement is being
used to back up the planning application
so that's the justification by why we
would be looking to do what we're doing
and because i've got the software to
back it up i can't incorporate in the
energy statement however you know as as
i believe was explained by the officer
during their presentation
we would be happy to to provide pv as a
matter of course on this development if
if members deem that an acceptable
condition
your next question
yes um
right so the
the other will say that we've got that
we've heard a little bit more about you
just talk about sorry yeah sorry i'm
just stopping
yeah as i said as explained earlier in
terms of what we've put before members
today is based on on-plot parking
provision only um i believe as the
officer explained
we've had further conversations and can
look to improve upon that
so trunking
to future-proof potential future
availability of ev would be a
consideration um
and on that basis i'm more than happy to
take that away and review that with
officers uh how we can stretch what
we've already indicated today to
increase those potential numbers
is there perhaps a condition there
it's too early
i'm just asking the officers that make a
note of that one please
we'll come back it's just yeah so the
the other yeah the other thing and
councillor ebon asked about um ndss
compliance and so on and i think the
answer was that
that there was over 50 of the affordable
homes
would not be compliant was that was that
the answer correctly that i understood
understanding is 51
would not be right and and and so one
presumably the the market properties
will be all compliant
um no so across this development um the
homes are not targeted to be ndss
compliant um that's something that's
come sort of stepped into uh modern
requirements for new build housing when
this application was looked at and well
considered under the outline it wasn't a
requirement and there's no policy
background to that however what
taylormade has tried to do where we can
is maximize the number of units which
are in the ss compliant
unfortunately we can't do that with all
of them
however in terms of our contacts with
the um
the housing associations um etc we're
not seeing that as a anything which is
holding up the the sales and occupations
of any homes um to present date
however it is something we're
considering looking at for futures
development thank you yeah
yeah thank you that you've strayed into
the by supplementary question really
about the um about the ndss
non-compliance and so on um
and my question was going to be
um are you confident that the social
um social landlords will want to take on
all these non-compliant properties and i
think you're saying yes they will are
you
yes however on
new developments they are pushing more
and more for ndss compliancy but within
this development um the registered
social landlord to whom we are using is
happy with the quantum of houses and
having no issues with having any
occupations
john you can't give a john
john it's not time for a view now that's
in debate it's questions
okay you done okay cancer possible
uh thanks matthew i just want to go back
to the points i raised earlier about
permeability of driveways because i
think it's really important as we live
in a really dry part of the country not
directly to do with highways it's the
permeability there because of the uh
scarcity of water and aquifers so would
you be
prepared to take that away and um
perhaps have that as a condition then
the other one i mentioned happy with the
planting scheme that's been dealt with
by jasmine um this issue about um
a reasonable number of swift boxes
swallow cups which most developers would
do
and i'm sure you'd be more than happy to
do that but could you confirm that
please thank you that's all
yes it answers both questions um in
terms of the permeability that's
something i'm happy to go away and have
a look at and see what we can do um
obviously we've consulted with the lfa
there's no holding objections towards
our drainage strategy on this
development so we're very happy and
content with that and pleased
that the lfa are also content in terms
of ecological enhancements um i believe
this the ecology would have all been
considered already at this stage however
um taylor mp actually goes above and
beyond um any policy requirements for
ecological enhancements and we have our
own sustainability banners
in the sense that we will look to
provide hedgehog highways back boxes
bird boxes etcetera and um i'm pleased
to say we'll go above and beyond any
policy requirements for that
okay thank you very much uh council two
more questions councilman cancer field
or the other right i hope this is a
brief one i just wanted to point out
that i'm looking at a company called
checker trade it says building rate
changes in 2022
and it goes on about the department of
leveling up homes and communities
introduce changes which will take effect
15 june 2022
is that wrong
it's correct it's basically you have to
have the plots registered uh under the
building rigs by june 2022
um and it's any plot you indeed you
start after june 2023 so there's a a
year's transition whereby it's a
registration element before you start
actually physically in the house thank
you for that clarity uh councilman
yeah thank you i'm going back to your
gas seating i'm afraid
are there any plans to install
underfloor heating which obviously works
with gas boilers and works very well
with
heat
pumps i think yes it's the short answer
um
with air source heat pumps i believe one
of your colleagues explained they run at
a much lower heating rate um it makes
far more sense therefore to have the
likes of underfloor heating being
utilized um oversized radiators running
at a lower um heat um i apologize to
keep referring back to the sap
calculations but when we spoke to
independent assessors that's where we're
being led towards so in all likelihood
on this development you will see that
coming into play without a doubt yes
with all likelihood
99 sure yes it will be the case
yeah can you make a statement all
properties on this development will have
underfloor heating i think that's going
to be subject to the sap software and
that's what i apologize to keep leaning
back on that but
at the moment when we spoke to
independent sap assessors it seems very
very likely we'll introduce um
underfloor heated to ground floors
oversized radiators and look to bring in
air source heat pumps in conjunction
with the building red shifts
that's where we are
i don't wish to deceive members by
making new pledges which i can't make
today but that's our full intention but
as of today we're still with gas until
we can make those calls
okay
every likelihood thank you thank you
very much okay so we're going to move on
now to
the ward members
we have two ward members first one
councillor humphreys uh please this is
from council humphreys please accept my
apologies not to be able to attend today
due to a late work commitment as ward
member i have no concerns on the
application again my sincere apologies
barry humphries
the other ward members councillor
morrison
who i haven't had any
correspondence from
okay so members it's over to you to
discuss debate and come to a conclusion
thank you i'm happy to start um
i mean obviously this site is a
continuation of of um
various sites phase one phase two a
phase two b so
um we kind of expect to see more of the
same really
and overall that's what's delivered i
think i'm just somewhat disappointed
that it is more of the same and
more could be done
on the overall energy efficiency so
including more renewables more um
you know
given this the state most people's
budgets household budgets are in today i
just think there could be a lot more
that can be done i'm very disappointed
about the space standards it's all very
well the um
housing
registered housing providers saying that
they'll accept the houses but you're
expecting people to to live in them some
of these
the space standards are 20
less than they should be in these in
these affordables and i'm i just think
that that's very poor and i think a lot
more could be done um given the company
of taylor wimpy's size that they they
should be
better on these kind of things
um
and i find it very interesting about the
rear parking course and there's been a
lot of discussion but i counted them up
there's 17 of them that i can see which
is a big number um and again i think
more could be done
there but i think my main concerns
really are just the overall energy
efficiency of the units on this site
that would help improve household bills
as well as kind of obviously
contributing
um in terms of less carbon and so on
but particularly the space standards so
as as the site seems to be you know it
is another extension of the previous um
developments across um chilton but
i just feel at the moment could do
better and i'd we wait to hear what my
the rest of my colleagues say thank you
chair
thank you council
uh thanks chairman yeah i mean if we
were to um i want to listen to what
others are going to say first um i am
inclined
um to support this but i do think there
needs to be conditions for example as
rachel was just saying about energy
efficiency
i would like to be convinced that we are
really maximizing what is being done
there and i think there is a there's a
degree of trust here actually we do have
other other developers as you said
chairman that do actually put down in
writing before the applications they
will
maximize the
other sources of energy i absolutely get
the efficiency bit that's very very
welcome so i'm not going to be over
critical and i do think the issue about
trunking is
john mentioned um for future proofing
for electric charging frankly that ought
to be common sense and we should be
doing that and i would hope that we
would be able if it is approved that we
would be able to work together as the
council the
jasmine the planning officers and
colleagues to deal with that and again
if it were to be approved i would like
to see a condition regarding the
biodiversity as explained earlier and
the permeability of the driveways so
i'll listen to the others but i am
inclined i'm not formally proposing
acceptance because there may be other
conditions that we need to add but i
would certainly if i were to support it
i want to have those um four items down
there and there's a say there will have
to be that degree of trust between
yourselves and the planning team to make
sure that there is at least a generous
movement to that direction and i know
you know i just remind everybody on page
37 we've got to look at these reserve
matters only and i know our hands are
somewhat restricted
because of that but um that's where we
are so we have to look at what we've got
thank you
thank you councilman
uh thank you chair i i think this
application is really highlighting
um a major issue in that the
outline planning commission was so long
ago and things have moved on
and i think what we've got here is is
very much a
you know almost a 20th century housing
development um and we're all really
disappointed in it
um
because things are move hopefully are
moving a pace
you know nationally regarding electric
vehicles and um heating energy resources
um and and
um whilst i completely appreciate that
this is meant to be the sort of higher
density part of the whole development as
a whole of the large development on the
side of stone market
and i and i welcome the open space um
and the bike paths and all that stuff
that goes with it i think that's
fantastic
but maybe i've got this little niggling
feeling that that
we're trying to cram too many houses
into this phase
i'm very concerned about the rear
parking course not just on the basis of
the fact that we have to put ducting in
for ev charging and i think that will be
a problem uh many many households will
have in the future
because of all the terrorist housing and
streets in that and here we are in a in
a development that's going to be built
post 2023
uh and it won't have ev charging points
and that just seems wrong to me
that's one of the issues with the rear
parking courts the other one is are
people actually going to park in them
because a lot of those houses that have
got parking in the rear parking course
have got a lovely bike path right in
front of them that are look to the
majority of residents as a nice big
piece of concrete they can park their
car on rather than let me cycle past it
nicely so i just i've got all these
worries about it um i completely agree
with councillor ebon's comments about
the space standards
um
if the house is too small to be
registered as a three-bedroomed house
then it should be a two-bedroom house
and then it would probably meet the
space standards so i don't quite
understand i know that there's this this
sort of trend that oh we can put a
a a tiny little bedroom in and call it
an office and actually it's a three
bedroom but actually it's a two bedroom
house we're going to call it three
bedroom but it's not a three bedroom
because you can't fit a bed in the third
bedroom um so there are all these little
niggling things and then find my other
my point i would just would like to make
is we appear to have false chimneys on
these houses um and that's yet another
source of heat leakage and um
things that look like things that
they're not um so they're just
they're almost not too many little
things that are bugging me for me to
really be supporting this application
much as i i welcome parts of it um and i
i just think you're right maybe we could
do a bit better
thank you
thank you yes this development has got
many
good features
including the obvious fact that
we need to deliver houses to the
population it's a necessary thing to be
doing
and uh
there is an outline coming transition
obviously to achieve that
the concerns really
are those others have expressed that
really we're just not being ambitious
enough about certain of the standards
whether that be
sticking
forced plastic chimneys on housing or
lacking ev charging points
um even commit permeable drives which i
thought were actually part of the
regulations but there you go
um
and
the critical ones the issues of heat
loss from buildings and heating
to an extent you can retrofit heating
providing your
designing the system to to
adopt the lower flow temperatures which
you get with different devices
we get arguments that say electricity
costs four times
what gas costs
which is painly true
but what it misses is the fact that a
heat pump generates at least three if
not four times the amount of heat per
unit of energy used of a gas boiler so
it's clearly a fallacy and clearly badly
argued
so
i find that so basically good
development but lacking ambition
certainly on the environmental front and
that impacts on the ongoing maintenance
and heating costs for the potential
occupiers
so we seem to be building things that
will be
[Music]
obsolete and require rework within a
very short period
you know i'm sorely tempted to suggest
rejection
the concern i would have there is that
then leads us to an appeal which is a
costly process
and delays housing which people
desperately need so
i shall continue to listen but i'm
certainly not particularly happy with
this development thanks counselor
mayor's got his hand up next and i'll go
after councilman
thank you
yes um i
echo much of what my colleagues have
said this development is disappointing
we're looking at layout
the layout is a layout acceptable if we
know that it is not future proofed and
will not allow charging of electric
vehicles in the future
the developer find it difficult to
install them now the residents will find
it even worse later on
but i have no doubt the officers will
tell us that we're judging the layout
based on legislation today
so whilst it is hugely disappointing and
i think it just lacks imagination
we've got a management company managing
the
um
common areas why can't the management
company manage ev charging points and
make a small charge they have cables for
lights they can have
it it is solvable um
so whilst it's disappointing
i struggle to find any reason to vote
against
um
and that's
that's the point i would put before my
colleagues
we might not like it but nobody has yet
come up i think with a justifiable
reason for not approving
this and i i look forward to hearing
what others have to say thank you
did you want to go first councilman
coming after you
yeah i
i would i would like to i mean i think
the
excuse me i i
i had also noted particularly to come
back to the point of electricity costs
four times gas and i'm grateful to
cancel the field i mean the the
the the relative costs of those are
moving rapidly in in
uncomfortable directions
and and apart from the the efficiency of
the use of the electricity
almost three times
what what's put in will be produced in
heat
um and and certainly the the underfloor
heating really wants to be a hundred
percent
um to make sense of this
um
there is the decarbonisation of the
electricity grid which means that in
sustainability terms
the electricity
will have a lower carbon impact and
we've had
people come
to
to put that point to us and say well
look we it's all right using electric
heating because after all the the grid's
only
60
fossil fuel or something now and um
that's
that is pulling against this at the
moment
very badly and i think
it's we inevitably have to think where's
this gas coming from
and um that's a problem which we won't
go into today
and i think apart from that there are so
many things
as other members have said but i i have
the advantage
or not really
of having been involved in watching this
site from its very inception in 2008 as
officers have said
and the the production of the design
brief and of the stock market reaction
plan which it's been a fundamental part
and so on and so on so i am i am more
than a bit disappointed i am very very
disappointed i look back and think about
some of the things that were
talked about back in those days we had a
place shaping group
and that group came up with a lot of
ideas
and and taylor wimpey were very
receptive at that time
and unfortunately for reasons i've never
understood place shaping groups were
stopped
so
latter phases have not had the
the continuous engagement that would
have probably solved some of the
problems that members have been
referring to
and
i am disappointed
looking at the whole the bigger picture
now
you know there are no allotments
we did not get the structural
landscaping arguing the toss about
whether the landscaping should be put in
this summer or next autumn
um it was it should have been put in a
dozen years ago
after one of two two of the trees if you
look at the landscaping you'll see there
are two blocks of green tpo trees the
gap in between
was
was very
cruelly created which led to the tpo has
been put on the rest of them that gap we
should have been trying to fill
10 years ago because by now we'd have
some trees there
we've we've
we've talked about the bus
service
bus
service
insofar as the bus service has been
created
into the
existing built out phase of this it's
been created by pinching
uh service away from from the bungalows
and elderly people in in roads like
saint edmonds road and and thermia drive
which
is not an addition to anything at all
it's it's it's subtracting from the
people that that needed it most
to to meet the planning condition
that said there should be a bus service
and and that's that makes me very
unhappy obviously the sustainability
generally
ought to be better than it is when we
were doing this in 2008
we were
working with an environment where the
the government of the day had said we
would have
will be building zero emissions
by 2015 and seven years from then
and and of course that got stopped and
here we are we can't even get
zero emissions being built in 2022-23
which is absolutely ridiculous frankly
and and you know i just i just cannot
support
the oh yes and the last point nearly
missed that one the the connectivity
of this
overall site
into stone market
is
is actually unsatisfactory we could not
get
we could not get satisfactory
cycling provision from phase one
into stone market now this one is a
little bit better
because of where it lies that the you've
got a different connectivity which is
better
but it's still not off-road
which it could be
could be through through um
what are they called now um
low traffic zones or something
um you know it is just so not good
enough that i just cannot actually
support it and and i think that the
point's been well made that the um
[Music]
about the you know that maybe that we're
just trying to put too many houses into
this space and i would just like to hear
from officers
the consequence if we approve 234 on
this 2c
how many are we required to squeeze into
on 2d
and what would be the density on 2d and
i think that is a question that is
actually some relevance to this phase
we'll come back to that question i think
i just need to remind you
that we are not being asked to decide
lots of things beyond we're only being
asked today to decide on appearance on
scale on landscaping and layout you've
got to be really careful when you start
talking about lots of things that are
not relevant to today's meeting so i
just remind you of that
um because you know this goes to appeal
and you're talking about things that are
totally irrelevant that we know where
that leads
um
so my view is i i don't disagree with
nearly what everyone said i think this
application is disappointing
it is uh i whoever made the comment as
it's in the past it is in that past
it isn't looking forward it's not
forward thinking
but
on what basis can i refuse it
i can't refuse it on space standard
because that's a new introductory thing
that came in since this was first given
permission so while 51 are not meeting
the space standard which is really poor
and it's really and i think council
manchester made the really good point of
why did you convert it to a two-bedroom
house instead of a three-bedroom to make
it you know but of course not because we
know why so it doesn't meet the space
standards currently but this is
from the past the eb charging points i'm
at a loss we have most developers who
come in and say it'll be secured
everywhere they'll be trunking in place
there's no questions asked that's a
given like broadband now
um
the triple parking is just about
acceptable the 17 parking course even
the applicants said
parking courts are not desirable
and actually i have been to parking
courts and people don't always observe
them
17 is too many now to me
appearance scale landscape and layout
parking courts is part of that so that
to me that fails the test on what's
before us today i don't believe this is
an appropriate layout
um on the ev charging points i think
more work needs to be done on the solar
panels well we've been told it will be
on every house but why isn't it just in
the application to give us that
confidence
um the heating we're told it is likely
to move but we're not 100 sure we're
talking it's likely to be uh um
underfloor heating but again it's not in
the papers so from my perspective and
here's where i need the advice of gemma
and ian please for me
i'm going to really struggle to support
this because it is so far removed from
what we would really want
but the policies i appreciate
are we're dealing with
policies from the past rather than
policies in the future
so to me we only have two options i
can't refuse it because i don't think
there's enough grounds from my
perspective i don't know what the
committee thinks but i'm really not
happy with it so
what happens if we defer it and ask for
far more discussions to go on around the
parking courts the trunking the heating
because some of those are around
landscape layout and scale and
appearance
yeah and a couple of questions more
questions yeah tim and well just very
quickly and i agree with everything you
said there matthew is it possible and
would it be compliant um asking our
planning colleagues here to put in the
conditions about energy
if necessary defer it fine but would it
be possible to condition things in order
to deal with those issues to work with
the
with the applicants to get them resolved
because you know i get the point about
the legislation where we are we all
understand that i do think it would be
very difficult to refuse it and i think
we we need to use some pragmatic common
sense here the i think that you've heard
the will of the committee or the various
views is it possible to condition it
in order to take this sword and get that
resolved i get it about the number of
houses that that's that's off the agenda
um as matthew said we've got to look at
pages 37 paragraph 12.1 those issues
about energy biodiversity i think we've
dealt with permeability the trunking uh
these sorts can we condition that
if we were to approve it or not what
would be reasonable i'm sorry to put you
on the spot no that's fine no problem uh
yeah absolutely there's some things we
can condition there are other things
that would be more difficult so the the
two things i think that we couldn't do
by condition would be the ndss i think
that as we said before has come in since
this outline was put up it's also not a
policy requirement so i think if we were
stuck on ndss i would say we don't have
the policy background unfortunately to
go and do that so we'd have to leave
that and the parking courts because
that's part of the layout either we are
approving or not i wouldn't say we could
do that by condition
on the positive side absolutely we can
do a condition on ev parking the u.s
members want that to include ducting to
parking courts we can certainly secure a
scheme for that the details of the
permeable driveway we can make sure that
we include in the sustainability scheme
jasmine has already put a condition on
but we can specify that that should
include pv provision to be agreed and
the biodiversity enhancement scheme that
you've mentioned we can certainly
condition all of those things and
equally if there are more details or
specifics that i haven't covered and we
want to add those in we absolutely can
does that help at all
um thank you chair i'd just be
you know i'd be happy to see stronger
conditions but i'd just be anxious about
giving what we've the the
disappointment we all feeling what we've
got today that those conditions
of being confident that those conditions
meet what we're asking um
and
if we defer but defend very very
specific points
for them to come back
so we know that those
um
that those can be met but equally um one
was mentioned i think um jasmine at the
beginning of your presentation that
ecology haven't even provided their
conditions yet so we don't actually even
know what
um any of those might be
so i would just be concerned that
i had the amount of things have been
raised that whether they can actually be
met i just want some advice on that i
mean certainly quality conditions we can
add those and that would be something we
would expect to do based on the ecology
comments we've got we'd also suggested
the biodiversity enhancement strategy in
any case so we would have that
controlled as well
but yes absolutely we'd expect to add
those in
i mean my other question would be would
you want this to come back to committee
if we go away and resolve those things
would you be happy to delegate to us on
those various points
i think what i would suggest is we drew
up a list of possible things that could
be added and then the committee votes
and if it takes you far enough only you
any individual members know whether it
takes them to that point of of finding
acceptable if that fails then we can go
to a second vote on deferring it but i
think that's that's the route i'd like
to go i think we should go for a vote on
with the with the um conditions and see
where members feel that takes them far
enough i think that's the logical route
if that's the route committee wants to
go down that's kind of what i'm hearing
i can't bring you back in i'm afraid uh
councilman mansell and cancer field um
yeah i i i am i completely get where
you're coming from about the parking
courts and uh allowing ducting for ev
is a compromise that that might be
acceptable
because
um if you
say okay we we're not going to accept
parking quarters at all
or we want fewer parking courts which i
got the impression that that's what
council hicks was trying to say
something about parking courts i i
honestly don't think you could cram that
many houses into that site and still
have all the delightful open space and
bike path so
so i think
we have to
if we're going to accept these parking
course i think they've damn well got to
have
ev charging ducting at a minimum
otherwise i really don't think that we
can we can have that many houses
in this space and still meet within the
open space provision that the outline or
the you know whatever indicative layout
uh promised us way back in whenever it
was 2018 or something 2017. uh and those
are all all the nice bits about this
this development so uh you know
i can't say i agree yeah
we can't we can't i don't think we can
get rid of those parts that's why i
think what we should do is we should put
a proposal forward for someone to
propose with all the conditions and see
if that takes members far enough
uh to support it if it doesn't then we
go to that would be my thought process
counselor feel do you want to come in
next
risk of saying the opposite that i
thought the deferment was the best
approach um
otherwise we aren't trying to
whatever it is right that look like the
law on the on the hoof while we're here
which is always a bit difficult uh i'll
go along with your view but uh let's
look at the reason i'm worried about
that is we actually we're all agreeing
what we want to condition so we might be
able to condition it now so that
actually it doesn't have to be deferred
but let's see where it goes
can i have someone who would be happy to
put that forward and then we can run
through the conditions and see where
that takes us counselor yes um in order
to move debate on chairman i'm happy to
put that forward um
to agree with a list of conditions
and then if that doesn't okay can i have
a second for that
do i have a second
cancer field okay so i've got a proposal
second or fourth recommendations but now
we're going to run through a list of
conditions that we would expect
to be 100 cast
iron conditions so should we run through
those around the room we've heard
various people
who wants to go first yeah councilman uh
uh we want we want ducting to the
parking spaces in the rear parking up
well to all the parking spaces or each
dwelling should have access to at least
one ducted ev point
we want permeable
driveways and rear parking courts or
whatever else you call a driveway
um we want um
maximizing the solar panels
um making sure the heating is exactly
not under um under things is it no we're
not allowed to do uh making sure they're
they're
whatever you know compatible with future
we can't do that one um what were the
other things we wanted to do
biodiversity um early planting of the
trees
um
yeah um
i'll let other people carry on now go
back to gemma or can you just can you
just talk about the solar panels what we
can conditionals over can we say solar
panels throughout and what can we do
about the heating
internally
i might draw in here but my advice would
be that
planning is always the position of
we shouldn't interfere where other
legislation dictates
so
therefore we shouldn't if something is
dealt with by building rings we
shouldn't go there did you
can we put informatives
i'm very happy to advise renault or an
information we could do an informative
that we expect this to be built to 2023
building rogues standards that but
2023 specifically because they have to
register it in 2022 to in order to use
the
which are kind of this i can say the
building rose 2383 is a given really but
if we want to have it as a as a as a um
yeah we can so at the moment i've got uh
ducting so that each each property has
one charging point as a minimum
permeable driveway solar panels
throughout
biodiversity and early planting
and as an informative 2023
building regs as a minimum
is there anything that i've forgotten
yeah cosmetics
yeah a bit more detail i mean the the
on on the on the biodiversity and so on
um
looking for the um you know swift brick
i think hedgehog highways are mentioned
house martin cups are not
he's already covered that you've got the
house martin's as well good right yeah
and then the other thing generally about
that is the um the warm light
not white light
uh biodiversity points which we
hopefully got to keep
having reminding last time until it
comes forward as i think that's pretty
standard now as well well you'd like to
hope so but
you know this is the one where
the developer is nodding it is standard
yeah
so yeah and um
yeah i mean i i think the the parking
the number of parking corps and layouts
and i really need an answer to the
you know what are we going to put in 2d
bearing in mind it's the edge of the
countryside and it's going to affect the
yeah we've got the ios we've got an
answer answer coming yep here we go uh
yes so as per i think it's in my report
so 3.2 of my report and basically we'd
expect 91 of the dwellings which is the
remaining amount to come forward in
phase 2d obviously we have no specifics
on
how that will look at the minute because
that will come forward in a separate
application which obviously members will
be considering
when that comes in
i couldn't tell you the density of the
minute um
i would have to yeah i'd have to kind of
measure it up
you see my point share the you know
the vulnerable
so i don't have the measure of the area
of land but i have been looking at the
um children lee's development brief and
that does expect a lower density towards
the bottom of the site so this is the
high density cluster through the center
as we come further south it releases
again it's a bit like round the edges
and to the bottom we would have a lower
density
so that is expected in the development
brief and appears to be what has been
followed through with the various
planning applications we've seen
cancer
well
on the comment of the density of face of
phase 2d
it's a very difficult question to answer
because some of that space is to be
sports grounds so even if you've got the
total area the density of the actual
housing bit will could vary depending on
how much land is given to sports
facilities
but we don't want to forget that we do
need a few more one-bedroom properties
in there
despite the fact it's low identity which
seems to be a little bit odd
okay so we're going to go to the vote
now
anymore
it's not about adding anything i just
think we need to think of them about
this very carefully because bearing in
mind i don't think either ward member
objected to this and the according to
the papers here there's no comment from
the town council and stone market and um
one house parish council they're
concerned we've dealt with so do you
think we need to think carefully about
this whatever our
views i agree and i think the other
thing we just got to think about is if
we go down a route of refusal what are
the grounds basically i'm only thinking
about appearance scale landscape and
layout so that's what i'll just put out
there for the last time but we'll go to
the vote it's been proposed by
councillor passmore seconded by
councillor field
with the additional points that we've
covered off
over to you
very happy thank you chair yep so we're
looking at the recommendation that has
page 37-38 of the report with additional
conditions is page three to four of the
table papers and additional conditions
which are easy parking condition to
include scheme production to all parking
courts so each dwelling has access to
one ev point details of permeable
driveways to be agreed sustainability
scheme to include pv provision
throughout and that's to be agreed
biodiversity enhancement scheme to be
submitted and the ecological conditions
as required by our consultee
an ecologically sensitive lighting
scheme early planting of landscaping
scheme and the informative note to
expect that the scheme will be built to
2023 building rig specifications
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
thank you members chair that's six votes
four and one against
could i just read something to you
before we start
before we just finished just to make
ourselves a little more happy
it says uh this is a something from a
government
thing from the department of leveling up
and all the rest of it
and it it says that the um
the new building rigs do not apply to
any building which has
where initial notice awful plans have
been deposited with the local authority
in respect to that building before 5th
of june 2022 and we are before the 5th
of june 2022
providing that the building work on that
building is started before the 15th of
june 2023
so i suppose that makes me more happy
that um
the new raids will apply unless they get
them built before 2023.
started
okay
members thank you very much the next
item on the agenda is site inspections
and we do have one to report taking
place
yes there's a site inspection on monday
yeah
and all details members have been sent
all the details so look forward to
seeing you then
okay so we've formally closed the
meeting at 11 24. thanks everyone have a
good rest of the day
you